I'm Amanda and I live yoga this is your
at-home yoga lower back workout
hey I'm Amanda I'm gonna take you
through some yoga postures for those of
you with low back issues start out on
hands and knees in the tabletop position
shoulders right over wrists hips right
over knees just take a couple rounds of
cat-cow
inhale look up exhale around and roll
through look at your navel inhale look
up exhale round through cat pose inhale
look up cow exhale roll through cat come
to a neutral spine separate the knees a
little bit wider bring the heels towards
one another start to reach the arms out
as you sit the hips back we're gonna
stretch out your pair formas your glute
muscles and into those outer hips take a
few breaths like that just stretching
the hips giving yourself a minute and
then you'll pull yourself forward into a
low Cobra position hands right
underneath the shoulders pull the wrists
pull the elbows in towards one another
so you can feel the shoulders wrap back
and up and then lift the chest up take a
breath in lift the chest a little bit
farther
exhale bring forehead down inhale pull
yourself up Cobra exhale bringing
forehead down any times like that inhale
lengthening up you want to keep the
tailbone long so tailbone is going back
towards the back of the mat deep breath
in exhale Green for a day to come up
back into that tabletop position Noreen
come onto our back to bring the knees
down walk the hips
over you lay and roll down onto your
back bring your right knee into your
chest
flex your right foot so you can release
and stretch through the low back the
para form is in the glute and the
outside of the right hip and then you're
going to reach around grab the outside
of the right foot with the right hand
take your left hand and anchor that left
hip down so you're still pushing low
back into the mat after that you'll take
me into chest again and then cross that
right ankle over the left knee reach
your right arm around grab the top of
the knee left arm around grab the top of
the knee and flex both feet a nice
static hold there I symmetrical and then
release that side really step right leg
and left and you'll come into the chest
flex left what's wrong and then slowly
release that feet down I just want you
to lift your hips up towards the sky and
start to walk the shoulders towards one
another and using your back of your legs
and stretching your tailbone down
this will help relieve any pressure in
the low back you don't want to start to
come all the way up just a nice gentle
lived here a few times you can lower
down and lift up if you're
you good you can start to lift the arms
over the head and then lower the hands
down you take the knees knees that just
squeeze these and let's start to gently
roll back and forth on the spine baby
side to side you roll all the way up
into a seated position so just a recap
that was cat-cow Child's Pose
Cobra half happy baby pigeon on your
back bridge pose rock up to seated and
that is your at-home yoga workout for
those of you with low back pain make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any other fighting weight episodes